Hey, listener, and welcome to Smart List. Before we get into this incredible episode, I want just a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Sean and Jason and I went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans from Brooklyn to Los Angeles. And guess what? Right now there are more live episodes from our tour on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on Wondry Plus,
after which you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. All right. Welcome to SmartLess. We got to make some kind of an announcement. Yeah, so like they have no, they can't use cell phones. Right, the case, your cell phones, they can't, we're sorry that we're running late. Yeah, but they should know that it's us making the announcements to what it's like.
We're making the announcements to what it's like. Somebody do it like in an accent or something. Okay, so please no flash. No, but in an accent, though, but in an accent. We tell them to turn on your mic. Can you turn on Sean's mic? Yeah, it's getting mic-shown. Let in an accent. Welcome to Chicago. Something like that. Yeah, and then what else are you gonna tell?
And then no flash photography. Right, and what else? And your fucking cell phone's away. Yeah. I think I can hear an echo like you might already be on. Stop, oh. Oh, am I excellent? Well then, you know what we have to say.
Uh-oh. Welcome to Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly!
Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Smartly! Hello, Zika-ga! What's up, Zika-ga? Oh!
Oh! Oh, man. Oh, man. Oh, man. Oh, oh. You know, you hear the music, you get all pumped up. Take a seat. Oh, please, sit.
Oh my goodness. Wait for me, see, I want to see the house lights. I want to see the house lights. I want to see everybody. Yeah! What were you thinking? By the way, thank you for wanting to meet us because we wanted to meet you. Why are we so curious?
Oh, wow. As will might say, you made a horrible mistake. Yeah. That's not the line, but find. Terrible, terrible. No, not the line either. Huge mistake. Okay. Huge mistake.
Okay, got it. For those of you who might not know or even care, I'm actually from here. Wow. So, I have like, I have like a zillion stories of how this place shaped me. Okay, give him a profile. Oh.
We literally just ate Portillo's, I'm not kidding. Oh. We did. We did. It was a real mistake. I've chewed five gas eggs in the last two minutes. By the way, also a true story. Yeah.
I've got a coffee on top of it. It's just, it's a bad science experiment. Anyway, thank you for being here and coming out tonight. It means the world to us and we're going to sit down now. Yeah. Oh, I got to do it, man. You guys. You guys.
You guys. You guys. Now, let me, this is your guest tonight. Are you relaxed? Yes, but I will be burping Pratilla's throughout the night. Do you want me to throw up some of my guess ex? No, no. Yeah, no, gross, gross.
And by the way, Sean thought it would be a good idea for all of us to have these beef sandwiches and chocolate cake, shake. Chocolate cake, shake. Before the show, and Jason, who hasn't had anything but a salad for the last, you know, four and a half years, it's tough on your system. I might need a stitch later. Oh no.
Wow. Here's stomachs like, what is this coming at me? Right. Wait, so I want to share a couple stories from my child. Since I grew up here, I can't remember how much of my mom's I told you about. Yeah. Oh, no, bless it.
This is going to be, so forgive me if you've heard this, but I don't think I've said this before on the podcast. But so this sums up my mom in like one quick story. She was the greatest mom ever I love her so much. She's since passed away. Sure, death, clap for death. And so, and she had a really dark sense of humor. So at two years old, she had cancer, so she had her,
her one of her eyes taken out. And she, you know, growing up, she had to keep resizing the eye. Resizing the eye. I'm not laughing at cancer or anything. I'm laughing because my family we would laugh because otherwise you'd cry. So we've made fun of it and she would make fun of it and whatever.
But hang on a second, what happens if you do not stay current with resizing the eye? Great question. Great question. Will it fall out with a sudden move? No, well, your face would grow as you grow, but the eye would stay tiny. Right, so it might fall out if you sudden move. No, well, your face would grow as you grow, but the eye would stay tiny. Right, so it might fall out.
If you do not resize it. Right, so as you grow older and then she had the five kids and my dad left, you know all that story when I was five and then my mom raised all the five of herself. Oh, they remember all these hilarious stories. And he didn't really leave. He put it in drive and punched it. I think is what it was.
It was a tire screech, right? So I also have a masturbation story that I want to get to. Sure, yeah, yeah. That anyway. So by the way, tonight on a very special smart list, what the hell? OK, so my mom then, so she raised five kids very self
and then to kind of give back when I had some extra money and I became tiny but successful, I was like, mom, I want to buy the house for you that we grew up and then the one next to it and the other side knock all three down and build you a house and that's what I did, which was fantastic. She deserved it, right?
And so, and so, tore our entire family apart, but anyway, so, And so tore our entire family apart, but anyway, so... LAUGHTER So... I love how I just enjoy you get out of your own pain. I mean, don't laugh you cry. So then... So this sums up my mom. So I put her in a condo while the house is being built,
and then I wanted to do like a big, like, reveal, right? And so the house is being built, and then I wanted to do like a big reveal, right? And so the house is being built, it took like a year and a half, and I furnished the whole, like all new furniture, like silverware, and like art on the walls, and sheets, and like the whole thing was just turnkey. And so she, I have that big move, that bus moment, right?
And so she, right, so she came in, so we're all there, the whole family's there, behind the door, and she comes in the door, and she immediately starts, she cries her eye out, and she is like, she's like, oh my God, this is incredible. There was only one dry eye in the house. And he wasn't real. So, okay, so anyway.
So then she walks in, she walks in, she's crying around, and she walks in, and she goes, she's touching everything, she's like, oh my god, nobody's ever done anything like this for me in my entire life. I don't know that I would have picked out that couch. And, uh, and that's my mom. Yeah. Oh. Yeah. Oh. Oh.
Yeah. And oh, my God. My sister, my sister, not your knee, if you're going to propose to me. My sister brought that gift for you guys today. Is that it? If that's her eye, is it an eye? Oh, my God. Please let it be the eye. Oh. Oh. Oh, it's her eye. Is it an eye? Oh my God.
Please let it be the eye. Oh. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh, oh, oh, oh. I can't see this, but it's an eye. Yes. Is that?
That's my mom's eye. Is this really your mom's eye? Yes. That's my mom's eye. Sorry. I brought my mom's eye. Sorry. I brought it back to Chicago. Oh, wow. So she's going to keep an eye on us for the show.
Wow. Isn't that nice? Oh, I'm curious. Is there a snow odor whatsoever? It's a pretty eye. It's a very pretty eye. She looks like when she got fitter for this, she may have been a little stone. Or just finished a long lap in a pool.
Mom, not my mom. No. She worked. Anyway. That's so nice. That's so nice. That's so good. Let's make sure we remember where that is.
All right. I'm surprised it's not a ball. Well, it's an eye. I know, but aren't our eyes round? Like, what did that? It's just like a cap. What would it stick to, I wonder? Well, should you have, like, I don't know.
But you know, like, there'd be like muscle and stuff. It's not like a... Maybe it was a ping pong, and then they put that on top of the ping pong ball. No, no, no. There was a little tiny... I'm not even kidding. A little tiny plunger suction cup. Then she'd go, and pull it out to clean it.
So she would take it out? Yes. And clean it? Yeah, hang on a second. And then wait. And then... And then when she would go out bowling on Thursdays, as I said this on the podcast, we would have friends come over and knock on the door, and there was a chain,
and we'd open the door with the iron and go, who's there? Like that, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh, OK. I want to meet you. Do you say you wish you'd met as my eye second, that? I wish you'd met my mom.
I did. I said in the car today, we were driving it from the airport, and I said, or maybe it was on the car on the plane. And I said, I really wish that I met your mom. She would have loved you guys. We would have loved her because we love you more than anybody. She was the best. She was the best.
Yeah. All right. So, is it Sean Hayes, the greatest? Come on. Let's get on. Come on. Everybody up, everybody up. Yeah.
Yeah. Get on. Get on. Yeah. Yeah. Everybody out everybody out The best What did I say today you make me what did I say I said something remarkably nice and I Plain you did it was really sweet. Well, we'll remember you could you forgot it so For my guest tonight guys., this is exciting. Right, I forgot. Yeah, yeah. I wanted to get someone who has some Chicago roots
and who is a friend to us three. Right, wait, we know this person. You know this person. This fellow went to University of Illinois and Columbia College. You might know it as soon as they said, he was in the original cast of the real-life Brady Bunch back in the 90s, which one of the funniest things ever saw.
He has since appeared in parts alongside Wolf Farrell and Elf Tell a Dig in Knights, and he's in the period in one of my all-time favorite TV shows that had his name in the title. Who? Now, he may not have had his own talk show with his own name in the title, yet, but he's the biggest reason Conan O'Brien did. It's Andy Mcer! No! No! Woo!
No! Andy! Hi! Hi, buddy. Hi, man. No! Let's go. Yeah.
Andy, great play. How are you? Hi. Hi, pal. Hi, pal. Hello. Hi, everybody. And they're the director. Hi, yeah. I was just talking about it, right? All we do is talk about you. I was like, oh, I got to keep it in.
I got to keep it in. And today, Andy tweeted out, and I read it to Sean. Yes. When we landed here, Andy tweeted out, he said, does anybody know a watch? No, I don't. I don't know. I gotta keep it in. And today, Andy tweeted out, and I read it to Sean, when we landed here, Andy tweeted out, he said, does anybody know a watch that's appropriate for fisting because I'm trying to make summer plans?
And I thought, well, that's a great tweet. Yeah, I mean, I'm traveling. And he should think of traveling, I'm thinking this summer, what can I do with myself? Sure. Single now, with myself? Sure. Single now. So sure. Sure.
You know, I'm just, Solomon Giorgio, who's a stand, a really funny standup, said, which hand are you gonna be using? And I said, probably the left, because I wanna keep the right free for the TV remote. Sure. Sure. Yeah.
Wow. Always multi-tasking. No, I know. You might want to hang out around Belmont after this, but anyway. How nice of you to come out here and join us. I am thrilled. Very cool of you.
Yeah, yeah. This is so exciting. Sean Astin, and I was really, was actually kind of lucky because I was like, I've, you know, like, I've listened to this podcast. I'm sorry. I know, it's okay. It's okay. I do a double speed, you know.
I'm unemployed, so I have a lot of time on my hands. But no, I really was like, after you asked me, I was like, was about to text like, hey guys, I'm gonna, and I was like, oh no idiot, it's supposed to be a fucking surprise. Well, yeah, all right. But did Smarty Pants tell you what's a surprise? Like, like, like, did he help you with it?
He did, he did. Not in the initial text. No, and he help you with it? Yes, he did. He did. Not in the initial text. No, no, and then I forgot. And then I forgot. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, and then you said, you said, the funniest text back. I was in my phone.
I said, hey, if you want to chat about anything like beforehand, and you're like, oh, I can't wait to read some of my poetry. I said, yeah. You said, you know, you want to know a little bit about what we'll talk about. And I said, well, first, I'm only talking about my poetry. This round loves it.
Yep. And secondly, I need at least 10 minutes to promote my new 24-year-old girlfriend, Lelani's vegan jewelry. Oh, good. Oh, we have a website on that, a web address? Yeah, yeah. There's a, we're bringing a screen in.
We're going to have a whole lot of people. Maybe you can sell the jewelry in the lobby when Sean comes here to do that play all right You're coming here to do a play. I could hear you. Yeah, what's another yeah Yeah, I'm playing anyway, so no, but speak of the jewelry. Have you seen Sean's new jewelry line? Wow, yeah, it's nice right? Oh, wow. Yeah, it's nice, right? Mandy. Yeah, that's what I mean.
Wow, that is weird. So, Andy, you're from here. When's the last time you were here? Do you ever jerk off in front of this? It's her him. I mean, it's a natural. We were all thinking it. That's so gross.
Where is the last time you were here? In Chicago, Thanksgiving. My daughter and I came out for Thanksgiving. Wait, but you didn't grow up? No, everybody's out in the western suburbs now. My sisters and my brothers are here with their families. But where did you go up? I grew up in Yorkville.
Okay. Yorkville. Yeah It's kind of by Aurora. You know, right? It's okay. No, that's all right. I mean, it's getting better, you know That it's it's that's how they have a portillos. No, I don't think they do have a portillos, but they have a water park now, which they didn't use to have. Oh, man, I bet it's nice right now. And at that town, the two probably most famous people out of Yorkville are me and Dennis Hastert. So yeah, to Mix Bag, right? Yeah, to Mix Bag.
What you know, you say you were here at Thanksgiving, this will always be bad, great mix bad. To mix bad. What do you know you say you were here at Thanksgiving? This will always be the iconic place for any sort of winter holiday because of the John Hughes films for me. Yeah. Like, nothing says winter cozy holiday than Chicago and the suburbs of it. I just, I fantasize about that.
Because you know, it's like 79 on Christmas in LA. It's like you want to blow your brains out. Yeah, I know. It's 79 years old. No, seriously, it's depressing. To sweat on Christmas? No. No.
These unbelievable coastal elites, right? I mean, you know, I'm Canadian. You guys are from Chicago, and then these guys, with their, anyway, it's a bunch of BS. No, you're right. You're absolutely right. It does suck. Wait, when you grew up growing up, you're one of the funniest people who I feel like
really hasn't gotten that huge opportunity to kind of have your own thing. Yes. Very handsy, so every job I get, I usually. No, but picked out. I know what you mean, though, Shunny's, you're the quickest, maybe one of the quickest people ever of all time.
But that's like, because of improv, right? In Provolympics. And I promised you how you started that through Chicago. Chicago. Well, I started out at University of Illinois and kind of, go along, I. And I started there, and I went there at Universe Villanoi and kind of... Goal on, I. And I started there, and I went there for two years, and then I decided to go to film school,
so I transferred to Chicago to Columbia College, and I got the fun thing after being out of the house for two years, got to move back home. Oh, man. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Yeah. What was the first big problem? Was it bringing a girl home?
Was it your home? That wasn't that big of a problem. But it should do. Dude, it should do. No. Did they find your bond? No, no. It's just my family.
And they're here. They'll test. They're really annoying. It's just my family. And they're here, they'll test. They're really annoying. I'm just... One asshole after another. And, you know, I mean, I'm pretty cool. So, yeah, contrast is very stark. Did you go through improv Olympic
with anybody that you've been to friends with? Yeah, actually Kate Flannery, which is great. She's great Meredith on the office. Yep. She was in my first improv class, and I've told her this since, but she used to, before each class,
she'd be furiously writing in a journal, and I always read over her shoulder to see whatever she was writing. It was always guy trouble. Yeah, yeah. Do you have any characters that you created there that you remember that you loved or was there any kind of improv game
that you loved that we could play right now? Oh, shit. Oh, god. I love that. Oh, yeah. Okay, really, you want to bring out the hoops and make us jump to him? I love that.
I love that shit. I think it's so fun. You're shot in character right now. Name in a plot. All right, You're showing a character right now. I'm naming a part of our art. All right, you're a space dentist. Go. And then, no, I mean, because you wrote a lot there, right? Yeah, but there's kind of like this macho.
I was in improv Olympic, which is del close, you know, school of improv. Yeah, yeah. And it's very, there we go. What event did you excel in? What event did you excel in? Being of improv. Yeah, yeah. And it's very, there we go. What event did you excel in? Huh? What event did you excel in? Being fucking funny.
Yeah. Yeah. No, well, it was all long form. Like, the idea was we would do this thing called a herald, which is a long form improv. You get a suggestion, and then you, you know, you're fuck around for half an hour, you do different scenes.
JB, like they do a dance yet. Yeah, yeah, it's like kind of like a dance. We last sawdys for a subject or a word. Well, wait, wait, wait, wait. By the way, for Tracy, who's actually here backstage, but she's not coming out. She's not coming out. Oh, my God.
She's not coming out. She's not coming out. She's not coming out. She's not coming out. Tracy. She's not. Tracy. Tracy. Tracy.. Tracey. Tracey.
Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey.
Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Tracey. Yeah Real life Tracy So she doesn't seem as dumb as Sean makes her sound It's gonna say explain what ask had is because it's such a great thing. Never mind. All right, so. Well, No Ask Cat is they know what it is.
Yeah, I mean, you all know it long for him. Improv is? I mean, it's fucking Chicago for Christ. But you were here at that time. What an unbelievable time. I mean, Chicago is basically the home of Improv in America. And it's where, yeah, it is. And all the people that, certainly,
all the people that I look up to who are great comedic, sketch performers and improvisers are all people who came out of it. I was also jealous. Somebody asked me once why I'd ever did sketch it. I said, I was too dumb to think about, I should go to Chicago and do that. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All these incredible people, forget the names are insane. Oh, yeah, I mean well like Matt Walsh I mean, I always like to say twice. I mean nominated Matt Walsh He had no he likes it even more when you say yeah, yeah, yeah, uh Faye Steve Correll, I'm like so many people. Yeah, Amy Sederis was here Paul De Nello Steve Correll We will be right back Steve Carell. We will be right back. This episode of Smart List is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn.
So guys, you know, Jason's not the only one who loves Skinny Pop. Will and I love it too. Me and Scotty love it. So whenever we watch a movie, Skinny Pop is our movie snack. We actually grab a bowl, we put the Skinny Pop to the rim, and we eat it like we're in a movie theater. It's like fantastic.
It's like you're at the movies, and I meet in Skinny Pop, and it tastes great. A deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt. Every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. Skinny Pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, staving off boredom, or unwinding after a long day.
In addition to the original popcorn, Skinnypop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle. Shop Skinnypop now at Amazon. Now back to the show. Tell me about like writing and did you enjoy that and how did you then parlay that into the culture? I was, I'm a terrible at writing. I mean, I'm good.
And I, and one of the reasons that I liked improv was because it was acting and writing all at once and I didn't get a chance to think about it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because when I sit down to write, I end up just like... Right. Yeah, it's so hard to say in the world. I said the kid that when I was a little kid, my mother put a desk in the basement facing a cement wall.
For absolute sensory deprivation to do my like third and fourth-grade homework Which was so easy to do and I would be like oh my god This will take 20 minutes. Why are you down here for an hour? Come on just try it and I'd be like one question go like oh my god It's like kryptonite In front of a brick wall. Yes, and that's not so healthy It was like because I just was so distracted. And then I just, you know, I just kind of, like my kids have 80-D too.
And like, will they ask, the only advice I have to them is like, well, you just have to do the work. Like, there's no secrets. There's no secrets. Yeah, this whole life, I'm, my whole, living my whole life with not being able to get shit done. It's like, oh yeah, right. Wait, do you have 80-D? You just do it. You have 80-D? I do, yeah, this whole life I've my whole living my whole life with not being able to get shit done It's like oh, yeah, right. Do you have 80 you just do it? You have 80? Yeah It seems like everybody's got 80. So like is it a thing and how do you know?
How about it's just like a lot of shit boring? No, no, it's a It's a real thing because there's a difference between... What's the ADHD? That's hyperactivity. That's me. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Get a load of me disease.
But how do you... Get a load of me disease? How do you check for it? How do you diagnose it? Like is there a test? Yeah, there's educational psychologists that can diagnose it. And there's medication to treat it? Speed, baby.
Are you giving these speed? Well, I mean, that's what Ritalin is. I actually was on ADD. What was on ADD? Yeah, Adderall. It's all just speed. And I went, I was on ADD meds for a while years ago. And then just because it's a,
raised your blood pressure and stuff, I set up taking them, right. But I would get a generic of, and I don't remember, it was Adderall or one of them, but I would get the generic and the bottle just said, and fed a mean. Oh, really? And one time, yeah, like one time,
I was shooting something down in San Diego on a marine base, and they're like, I have to go through your bag and it's like, and fed me. Yeah, yeah, those are pretty much the same. You're scratching and snorting. Uh-huh. So then how did you and Conan meet and how did that happen?
Um, well, there's, uh, there's like some classified ads out in LA. Uh-huh. Lonely people. No, I, what, you mentioned the real library, Brady Bunch. That's what, for Tracey, if you're listening, or anybody who doesn't know, real library, Brady Bunch was kind of like a state.
An annoyance theater production in the era of Brady Bunch episode. Yeah, annoyance theater. Yeah, it was so fucking funny. And by the way, Sean, sorry, I just love seeing you go, like, just so naturally. And by the way, Tracy, and you're just looking at wings. Are you less than, yeah.
What character's you playing real life pretty much? I played Mike Brady. I mean, but that was like. That's the dead, right? Yeah, that's the dead. Because I mean, we're in Robert Reed. It's been a while. Fucking dead ringer.
No way, I put it in, so it's Mike Craig, Peter Bobby, right? Yeah, thank you. Right, right, there you go. That's really good. I think you're really deep in love with a thing. I'm not quick or bright. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Wait, so I have A to D. What did you say?
I played Mike Brady, but that was. But I was like the third or fourth Mike Brady. It was when it went from Chicago to New York, the guy that was playing Mike Brady, also worked at the Innoence Theatre, like had a, you know, he was like a salary person there. So he couldn't go to New York. So I asked Joey Salahue, can I go along, you know, buy me a cheap wig? All right, you know? So was it like that tight curly wig?
Oh, it was awful. It was seriously like a $17 wig that was like a bathing cap with hair on it, you know? So I feel like I got a bit of a Carol Brady going right now. I need to cut this flip. It need a little bit longer. Oh yeah, yeah. Looking Lynch played Carol Brady in the show,
and she had the just like the shittiest, like little Carol Brady flip that had like a, just an elastic strap that she like hit under her pants. That she just would strap on, you know, who played Alice and how was she? Mary Wiesen, she was great. She was sort of originated the role here. She's kind of like a more musical theater person.
I would have played Tiger. That would have been fun. The dog. Wait, well, it was such a big thing that we all pitched in. You know, it was like, when I heard they were gonna do it, I thought it was the dumbest fucking thing I've ever heard. Right. And then when I saw the first night of it,
I don't know that I've ever laughed harder. Sean, you saw it. Yeah, a long, long time ago. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because everybody in it was really town. Oh, my God, really. If you met Conan there? No.
I did not. That, uh, see, you got to bring him back on track, guys. Right, right. You. You got to keep your eye on the prize. I, uh, I, we went to New York and then the Brady Bunch moved to LA and I went to, I went to LA with the Brady Bunch. And in the meantime, Betty Kale, a Chicagoan, uh, who is a friend of mine that I went to
Columbia College with, she had, she was on SNL for a season. And that summer, she was in LA. You point a lot, and I, you was in LA. Do you point a lot? You point, Constellate? Yeah, yeah, yeah. This, it's my Bernie Sanders imitation. Um, and then we, no, we, um, she comes out to LA. She comes out to LA.
I hang out with her. She's friends with Robert Smigel. I meet Robert Smigel. Robert is, is going to be the head writer on Conan Show and says, do you want to meet Conan O'Brien? Did you know Conan was at the time? Was Conan already on the air? I knew that he was the guy.
When the question had a time, man. No, no, no, no. He had just done like a screen test kind of thing. And I just was just announced this guy who was a comedy writer on the Simpsons is going to be the replacing David Letterman. I just heard about it like anybody else. And then like two days after it happened, I went to Jeff Garland was taping a pilot in LA where he played like a New York cop, like a lovable guy, which, you know, Garland as a cop,
is of course, he's absolutely a cop. Yeah, totally the world's own. Chattiest cop. Yeah, exactly. But I actually went to that with Kate Flannery, and we sat in front of Bob Odenkirk, who is there with Carol Leifer. Yeah, yeah, I feel.
当然是，他绝对是个警察。对，完全是世上最健谈的警察。对，没错。但我其实是和凯特·弗兰纳里一起去的，我们坐在鲍勃·奥登科克的座位前面，他和卡罗尔·莱弗也在那儿。对，对，我觉得。
And I totally, totally eaves Eve dropped on them talking about Conan, because Bob is very good friends with Conan. And Bob actually, Bob and his brother Bill, actually in the beginning of late night, came out and wrote on the show for a couple of months. And guess. And Bob and Conan were roommates at one point. Yes, here in Chicago, here in Chicago.
而且我完全、完全偷听到了他们谈论柯南，因为鲍勃和柯南是很好的朋友。而且鲍勃，其实鲍勃和他的弟弟比尔，在深夜秀刚开播的时候，曾在节目组当过几个月的编剧。你猜怎么着。而且鲍勃和柯南一度还是室友。没错，就在芝加哥，就在芝加哥。
Yeah, during the right, they were working on SNL, and during the writer's strike, they came here and they did a live show. This is Bob's Michael. Bob Odin. Oh, Bob Odin. Bob Odin was in that show too. Robert's Michael. Bob Odin Kurt.
对，在编剧期间，他们在做《周六夜现场》，在编剧罢工期间，他们来到这里做了一场现场秀。这是鲍勃的迈克尔。鲍勃·奥丁。哦，鲍勃·奥丁。鲍勃·奥丁也参加了那个节目。罗伯特的迈克尔。鲍勃·奥登科克。
Conan. Jeff Garland was here at that time, so I think they stayed here. Unbelievable. I mean, just heavy hitters. So then, how did you get from meeting Conan there to becoming such a close friend with him and then becoming the co-host of the Conan O'Brien show? Right. Look at you, they're cheering on for you.
柯南。杰夫·加兰当时也在芝加哥，所以我想他们就住在这是吧。难以置信。我是说，全都是大腕。那你是怎么从在那儿遇到柯南，到后来和他成为如此亲密的朋友，并最终成为《柯南·奥布莱恩秀》的联合主持人的呢？对啊。你看你，他们都在为你欢呼呢。
They've gone to Matt and ADHD. We try to sit them in the front. Yeah, yeah. Look at him go, asking questions like a big boy. What was the moment that you and Conan met? We arranged lunch in Los Angeles at Junior's Delicateson. Oh, sure.
他们去找马特和多动症了。我们尽量让他们坐在前排。对，对。看他那样子，像个大男孩一样问问题。你和柯南相遇是在哪个时刻？我们在洛杉矶的朱尔斯熟食店安排了一次午餐。哦，当然。
And no longer there. I ordered food, Conan ordered a can of coke. And I was like, because for me, it was someone who was paying for lunch. So, bring it on. And we just hit it off really well. Immediately, we could be as stupid as we wanted with each other. Was it just to be friends or was there?
现在已经不在了。我点了吃的，柯南点了一罐可乐。当时我就想，因为对我来说，那是有人请客吃饭。所以，放马过来吧。我们俩一拍即合。立刻就能像个白痴一样无拘无束地互相对话。那次见面只是为了交朋友还是有别的？
No, we didn't get a job as a writer on the show. As a writer. You think it was a date? Well, I don't know. I mean, they're both handsome girls. I don't see how it is, but you know, that's what I'm saying. We were spooning in a booth.
不，我们当时没在节目里找到编剧的工作。作为编剧。你觉得那是约会吗？嗯，我不知道。我是说，他们俩都是帅小伙。我不明白怎么会是，但你知道的，这就是我想说的。我们在卡座里像勺子一样紧紧相依。
But, but, but, so because the notion of you being on the couch I'm just a douche. You know? That's not funny. We were spooning in a booth. But because the notion of you being on the couch with Conan during that show all the time was never really part of the plan, Questermark? I'm not supposed to say it like that. Rising intonation I could tell. Okay, good. You're not talking to Siri. Yeah, yeah.
但是，但是，但是，因为你经常和柯南一起坐在那档节目的沙发上，这从来都不是计划的一部分，对吧？我本来不该这么说的。我能听出语调上扬。好吧，很好。你又不是在对Siri说话。对，对。
Yeah, yeah. He does, by the way, he does do so much of dictating his text while he's driving. So and you know people who do this, but you'll be in a room. We'll be all in the room. We've been on the road now for like a week or whatever. And Jason will be in the corner and he'll be going, hey honey, are you there? A question mark. I'm just going to dot, dot, dot, dot dot dot dot dot dot Call me back and get a second comma and envelope
对，对。顺便说一句，他开车时确实经常通过语音转文字来发短信。所以，你懂那些这么做的人，但你会在一个房间里。我们全都在房间里。我们现在已经在路上呆了一个星期左右什么的。杰森就会坐在角落里说，嘿，亲爱的，你在吗？问号。我只要点、点、点、点、点、点、点、点，回电话，再加个逗号和信封。
I can't wait to see you I tell it x o x o smiley face emoji hard emoji Kiss emoji Who doesn't who doesn't that? But wait so so I got hired as a writer, right, right. And there was like an implicit promise that you're gonna perform at some point, too. And then just as the show evolved
我等不及见你了，亲亲抱抱，笑脸表情，大心表情，飞吻表情。谁不会，谁不这么干？但等等，所以我被雇为编剧了，对吧，对吧。而且当时有一种心照不宣的承诺，就是你以后也会进行表演。然后随着节目的演变。
and he started doing test shows in studios around... He realized he wasn't enough. No, no. Robert's Michael. I mean, no, that's still a few years off. Yep. But he... No, Robert's Michael, I mean, no, that's still a few years off. But Robert's Michael just went, go sit with him and keep him company. And which like, we worked together long enough to know like,
他开始在各地的演播室进行测试演出……他意识到自己还不够。不，不。罗伯特的迈克尔。我是说，不，那还要等好几年呢。没错。但他……不，罗伯特的迈克尔，我是说，不，那还要等好几年呢。但罗伯特的迈克尔只是说，去和他坐在一起，陪陪他。就像我们合作得够久了，知道……
oh yeah, that's something that needs to be done. You might have made it to him. But was the guy who did the little mouth thingy cut into the face, right? Saddy TV fun house. Are you talking about the triumph the insult dog? Yeah. But he also was the guy with the mouth behind. Yeah, we did. Oh, on Conan when they put the other mouth.
哦，对，那是需要做的事情。你可能已经向他表白了。但那个用小嘴巴对着脸做出各种表情的家伙是谁来着，对吧？疯狂电视秀。你说的是侮辱狗凯旋吗？对。但他也那个带嘴巴的人。对，我们做过。哦，在柯南节目里他们加上另一个嘴巴的时候。
Yeah, we call this clutch cargo. Wasn't that what's that his hand? Or no, I'm thinking of the in-laws. Oh, man. We've Peter Fault about that. That's senior Wences. I'm so old, you guys. This is all starting to go.
对，我们把这叫克拉奇·卡哥。那不是他的手吗？或者不是，我想的是《亲家》。哦，天哪。我们为此谈论过彼得·福尔克。那是温塞斯老头。你们这群人，我太老了。这些全都要忘光了。
So wait, I've always thought, because obviously we love Conan. He was on the tour with us already. He's amazing. But I always thought when I watched it, every single kind of wisecrack you kind of cut in with or any, it was always fucking so funny. You just waited and then you went,
所以等等，我一直以为，因为显然我们都爱柯南。他之前就已经和我们一起巡演过了。他太棒了。但我一直以为，当我看着的时候，你插话说的每一个俏皮话，或者任何一句，都他妈的太搞笑了。你只是等着，然后你就说：
bam, like right in there. And I was like, he could have his own talk show. Is there any kind of aspiration to do that? Because it seems like you could so seamlessly. Did you ever try to kill Conan? Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha. I never did try to kill him. And honestly, it was, I was happy to have that position.
砰，直接切入。当时我就想，他都可以有自己的脱口秀了。有没有想过要那样做？因为看起来你做得天衣无缝。你有没有试图谋杀过柯南？哈哈哈。我从来没想过要谋杀他。老实说，能有那个位置我已经很高兴了。
I would not want, like, there was so much of just the time that I've spent being his TV wife. There was so much stuff that he had to deal with, that he kind of likes dealing with, and that I'm just like, lemme alone. He has to have so many meanings, and he has to know so many... It's a lot. ...puky, you know, like executive types.
我才不想，就像我花那么多时间扮演他的电视“妻子”一样。他要处理的事情太多了，他其实还挺喜欢处理这些事的，而我只想说：别理我。他得开那么多会，还得认识那么多……这可真够累的。……那些恶心的，你知道的，高管类型的人。
Remember their name. I don't know anybody's name. I don't have to say. You just want to do bits. I just want to, yeah, just, I want to show up. I want to make television. I want to make funny stuff. And I don't want to have a bunch of boring meanings.
记住他们的名字。我谁的名字都不记。我不用说。你只想做小品。我只想，对，就是，我想露面。我想制作电视节目。我想创作有趣的东西。我可不想开一堆无聊的会。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Baby wants fun. Yeah, yeah. I bet you both these guys would agree that anytime we were on that couch, the idea that you were right here the whole time was very comfortable. Yeah, very, very comfortable. It was like, it was great. I love it. I was smelling your hair. Yeah, I mean, that's hard not.
对，对，对。宝宝想开心。对，对。我敢打赌你们俩都会同意，我们在那个沙发上的任何时候，一想到你从头到尾都坐在正中央，就觉得非常舒适。对，非常非常舒适。感觉就像，太棒了。我太喜欢了。我在闻你的头发。对，我是说，那很难不……
That's the comforting. But it's mostly the blue. Again, you know, not unlike Chicago, you were at Conan at a time when you guys started doing that show, you really kind of once again broke the mold. David done it with Letterman in the 80s. And then you guys read it. You had amazing writers, most of whom were sketch performers or a lot of them from Chicago. Who came.
那感觉真令人安心。但主要还是因为蓝色。再次说明，你知道的，就像芝加哥一样，你们在柯南的那个时期，当你们开始做那个节目时，你们真的是再次打破了常规。大卫在80年代用莱特曼做到了这一点。然后你们又做了一遍。你们有出色的编剧，其中大多数都是素描喜剧演员，或者很多来自芝加哥。他们来了。
It was a real Chicago Boston kind of split. It was unbelievable. And you guys did so many unbelievable sketches. You guys remember in the early 90s and late 90s, whatever. There were so many amazing moments. Yeah. Being there at that time, was it every day where you like, fuck yeah, I'm so psyched to go in there and do these bits and work on this show.
那是一种真正的芝加哥和波士顿的结合。真是难以置信。你们做了那么多难以置信的小品。你们还记得90年代初和90年代末等等的时候吗？有那么多精彩的时刻。对。身处那个时代，你是不是每天都觉得，他妈的太棒了，我太兴奋能去那儿表演这些小品并制作这个节目了？
No. Great. Good night. Good night. I mean, you know, it's like. What do you mean, no, you weren't? No, not every day. I mean, you know, what am I?
没有。太棒了。晚安。晚安。我是说，你知道的，就像。什么叫没有，你不是吗？不，不是每天。我是说，你知道的，我又算什么？
How was the... I mean, you know, for this... What's the worst? What's the worst? But the worst? My shorts are the big long. Well, you need to learn to appreciate it. How heavy was the lift though?
当时的情况是……我是说，你知道的，对这个……最糟糕的是什么？最糟糕的是什么？但最糟糕的是？我的短裤又宽又长。好吧，你需要学会欣赏它。不过工作强度有多大？
I mean, like, you'd get in there, you guys would shoot what about five o'clock, right? Well, no, it was... In the beginning, it was brutal. So you were on 47 weeks a year, five days a week. How long was the day for you? You'd get in at what time? It's late at what time?
我是说，比如说，你进去，你们大约五点钟拍完，对吧？嗯，不，是这样的……一开始，那简直残酷。所以你一年要干47周，一周五天。你的一天有多长？你几点到？几点结束？
10 a.m. and usually leave around midnight. Really? In the beginning. Every day? Yeah, I'm out. Just because you're 14 hours. That's what I want to write. What's your bits?
早上10点到，通常午夜左右离开。真的吗？一开始是这样。每天都这样？对，我受够了。就因为你要工作14个小时。那就是我想写的。你的小品是什么？
Write bits, produce bits. What's the staff for? Well, when I got hired, I was a writer. You know, I was on the show too, and then they began... What do I mean? No, I know. ...to look at how tired he is thinking about it. Oh, I mean...
写小品，制作小品。那员工是干什么用的？嗯，我被雇用的时侯，我是一名编剧。你知道的，我也是节目的演员，然后他们开始……我这是什么意思？不，我知道。……看着他一想到这事就觉得有多累。哦，我是说……
What do I mean if... Hey, portal to portal. No, no, no, no, who said you your suit? I went on a one hour show, though, you would think it would be a shorter day, but not every... Can I just tell you something? This is really on brand for this. And I just want to talk about what happened
如果我刚才说的是……嘿，门到门。不，不，不，不，谁说你的西装了？不过说真的，这是一个一小时的节目，你本以为工作时间会短一些，但并不是每个……我能告诉你们一件事吗？这真的很符合这里的调性。我只想聊聊今天后台发生了什么。
backstage today. Oh my god. Hang on, can I just tell you where we came out? Yeah, so I want to just want to say, so everywhere we go, we've been on tour for a week. And Andy, you're going to appreciate this because you've known Jason for a long time. By the way, I drank out of that.
哦，天哪。等一下，我能先说说我们是怎么出来的吗？对，所以我想说的是，我们所到之处，我们已经巡演了一个星期了。安迪，你会欣赏这一点的，因为你认识杰森很久了。顺便说一句，我刚用那个喝过水。
Yeah. I don't care. It's been super easy. And his mom's eye came in that too. So, everywhere we go, we have the special water and almonds and popcorn. And, I didn't ask for any of it. So, Jason starts going, it dawns on him
对。我不在乎。这超级轻松。而且他妈的眼睛也流进那个里了。所以，我们去任何地方，都有特殊的矿泉水、杏仁和爆米花。而且，我什么都没要。所以，杰森开始觉得，他突然意识到……
and I'm like, everywhere we go, we're the popcorn and the almonds and the lemon water. And they're like, where is this coming from? And we find out. Well, look, I, hey. Hey. But I said, I said, it dawned on me, that like, all my favorite things.
然后我就想，我们去哪儿都有爆米花、杏仁和柠檬水。他们就问，这都是从哪儿来的？然后我们才发现。好吧，听着，我，嘿。嘿。但我要说的是，我突然意识到，这全都是我最喜欢的东西。
Because we're all saying in the same hotel room, we thought it'd be fun and funny. It's a fucking drag. Are you really? So are you really? Yeah. We're all saying this is same hotel room. We thought it'd be fun and funny. It's a fucking drag. Are you really? So are you really? Yeah. We're always saying that it's fun. It's great.
因为我们都住在同一个酒店房间里，我们觉得这会既好玩又有趣。这他妈太折磨人了。你真的是这么觉得吗？所以你真的是……对。我们都住在同一个酒店房间里。我们觉得这会既好玩又有趣。这他妈太折磨人了。你真的是这么觉得吗？所以你真的是……对。我们总是说这很有趣。这太棒了。
But all my shit is in there. This lemon perfect. A great beverage. I highly recommend it. It is a great beverage. Almonds. Daddy likes almonds. There's a certain kind of candle
但我的所有破烂都在那儿。这个柠檬特饮。一款极佳的饮料。我强烈推荐。它确实是一款极佳的饮料。杏仁。爸爸喜欢杏仁。还有某种蜡烛……
that I do like a nice smelling candle. Yeah. And by the way, and there's skinny pop pop. And every time I walk in, I go, scan a pop. OK, so, but I realized that whomever was tasked with getting this stuff in the hotel room, in the dressing room, I must think, I'm a fucking monster. Yeah. But so on. Right, so the point think, I'm a fucking monster. Yeah.
我确实喜欢气味怡人的蜡烛。对。而且顺便说一句，还有瘦子爆米花。每次我走进去，我都会说，瘦子爆米花。好吧，所以，但我意识到，无论谁负责把这些东西弄进酒店房间、化妆室里，一定觉得我他妈是个怪物。对。所以……对，所以重点是……觉得我他妈是个怪物。对。
But, but, but, so, but the point is, I'm trying to find, but I'm trying to, because I never asked for it. I'm trying to track down. It must be one of my friends from back home that told whoever's arranging things here, oh by the, I just want to make sure they say, don't make the mistake of not having X, Y, and Z.
但是，但是，但是，所以，但重点是，我想找到，但我正试图去找，因为我从来没要过这些。我正试图追查到底。这一定是我老家的某个朋友告诉这里负责安排的人，哦，顺便说一句，一定要确保他们有X、Y和Z，千万别漏掉。
I hope it was like, oh by the way, just if you've got something, you know, Jason happens to like, such and such, and I think the guy's like it, too. It wasn't like that. It wasn't like that. And the best part was, Jason was like, how come there's nothing for you and Sean don't have anything? And I was able to, you know, when you get on the high road? And it's open.
我希望当时的情形是，哦，顺便说一句，如果你有什么东西，你知道的，杰森刚好喜欢某某东西，我想那家伙也喜欢。事情才不是那样呢。根本不是那样。最棒的是，杰森当时说，怎么你们俩什么都没有，肖恩也没有任何东西？然后我就能够，你知道当你走上康庄大道的时候？它是敞开的。
And you're able to be just super chill on the high road, and you go, because we don't need anything. And it's open. And you're able to be just super chill on the high road and you go, because we don't need anything. But wait, Andy. Andy, I want to get that. I know, I know. I know, I know. I know.
然后你能够以一种极度超然的心态说，因为我们什么都不需要。它是敞开的。然后你能够以一种极度超然的心态说，因为我们什么都不需要。但等等，安迪。安迪，我想听那个。我知道，我知道。我知道，我知道。我知道。
I know. So wait, I would show you. You remember the time, the time that you, there was some kerfuffle about you in line at the Apple store? Oh, cool. And you got, do you all know about, yeah, they didn't see it, they clearly already know it.
我知道。所以等等，我要说给你听。你还记得那次吗，就是你在苹果商店排队时引起的一场轩然大波？哦，酷。然后你被……你们都知道这事吧？对，他们没看过，但他们显然已经知道了。
Oh my God. We were just going to talk to about it. That was so hilarious when I happened. And I think I saw you like the day after and you were like, I was not cutting the line. But wait a minute, I want to get back, I want to get back to the story. I put the story so they know.
哦，天哪。我们正准备聊这个呢。那次发生的时候太搞笑了。我想我大概是你出事第二天看到你的，你当时说，我才没有插队呢。但等一下，我想回到正题，我想回到那个故事。我把故事讲出来，这样他们就知道了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I want to get back to just a little bit about Chicago. Because Chicago, I know. Hey, Sean. Hey, what's going on? And I want to get back to Chicago. And everybody knows there's so many great music and great bands and everything like that. Are from here, did you have anything
对，对，对。我想稍微聊聊芝加哥。因为芝加哥，我懂的。嘿，肖恩。嘿，怎么了？我想回到芝加哥的话题。每个人都知道这里有很多伟大的音乐、伟大的乐队和诸如此类的事物。都是从这儿出来的，你小时候有没有过……
like that growing up where you just anybody you loved or maybe somebody now or whatever? Because I love, I was in a band called Sounds From The Stairs. Hold for a while. That's for a five-year. What was Sounds From The Stairs? It was all keyboard again. But what was the significance of the name?
那种经历，比如任何你深爱的人，或者现在的某个人什么的？因为我喜欢，我曾在一个叫“楼梯回音”的乐队里待过一段时间。持续了五年。什么是“楼梯回音”？那又全都是键盘。但这个名字有什么深意吗？
None of your business. Wow. Sounds from the stairs. It sounds like they started practicing in the basement of Bob's Hall. That's exactly what it was. That's exactly what it was. What kind of songs?
关你屁事。哇。楼梯回音。听起来像是在鲍勃大厅的地下室里排练的乐队。完全就是那样。完全就是那样。什么类型的歌？
Oh, just synth pop, you know. Well, an example. Like, we would do covers of the cure. Oh, my God, it sounds so cringy. Sean doing synth pop. Did you have a smoky eye? Ha-ha. We'll be right back.
哦，就是合成器流行乐，你知道的。给个例子。比如，我们会翻唱治疗乐队的歌。哦，天哪，听起来太让人脚趾抠地了。肖恩在搞合成器流行乐。你画过烟熏妆吗？哈哈。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. So I would be, you know, like, when you play keyboards in a band, you can't really like, you know, jam like you can in guitar. Because you can't jump, because you missed the keys. So I'd be like, no, right, the key, right, but I only played synths, so I'd be like, I'd be jamming out, and then whenever it was my turn to, play I'd go. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band.
现在回到节目中。所以我会，你知道的，就像，当你在乐队里弹键盘时，你其实不能像弹吉他那样去即兴狂欢。因为你不能跳跃，因为你会按错键。所以我就会想，不，对，那个键，对，但我只弹合成器，所以我就想，我会一边即兴演奏，然后每当轮到我solo的时候，我就会……哈哈哈……不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。
Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band.
不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。
Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in the band. Not in. Wilco is in the city. Well, it's so funny because we keep, these guys turn me on to Wilco and I was reading about Jeff Tweedle and how incredible he's reading. No! I mean, Tweedle. No. Tweedle, I can't even say. Tweedle, hang on, let me just finish.
不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这乐队里。不在这。威尔科乐队就在这个城市里。好吧，这太搞笑了，因为我们一直在，这几个人让我迷上了威尔科，我当时在读关于杰夫·特维迪的文章，以及他是多么不可思议。不！我是说，特维迪。不。特维迪，我甚至都说不出口。特维迪，等等，让我说完。
Jeff Tweedle, about how. You're fired. Hang on. I was waiting, I was waiting. I just wanna make sure we got that, right? Yeah. I was waiting. I was waiting. Yeah, right? Yeah. I was reading it. Yeah, we don't.
杰夫·特维迪，关于他是怎么……你被解雇了。等等。我一直在等，我一直在等。我只是想确保我们弄清了，对吧？对。我一直在等。我一直在等。对吧？对。我当时正在读。对，我们才不……
That is a perfect example of something. Listen, let's have to go through the Sean Hayes filter. Yeah, yeah. I was reading about Jeff Tweetie and how amazing he is. And he's not only like a songwriter and a musician and a record producer and a Grammy winner. He's also here. Jeff Tweetie!
这绝对是一个典型的例子。听着，让我们通过肖恩·海斯过滤器来筛选一下。对，对。我当时在读关于杰夫·特维迪的文章，以及他有多么了不起。他不仅是个词曲作者、音乐家、唱片制作人、格莱美奖得主。他还是……现场的。杰夫·特维迪！
No! No. Whoa. What? Wow. Wow. Wow. I know you. I know you.
不！不。哇。什么？哇。哇。我认识你。我认识你。
I never met you. That's in the middle. All right, sitting in the middle. Right. Oh, my God. This guy's great. He's breaking out right now. Yeah.
我从没见过你。那是坐在中间。好吧，坐在中间。对。哦，天哪。这家伙太棒了。他现在要爆发了。对。
Have you never met him? I have met him. I met you on a tour bus, but I was not in a real good place to talk, because I'm a little... I was a little star-struck like I am now. Oh, no. Good, good. It's so cool that you're here.
你从来没见过他吗？我见过他。我在巡演大巴上见过你，但我当时状态不太好，无法交谈，因为我有点……我有点追星，就像我现在这样。哦，不。很好，很好。你能来真是太酷了。
Thank you. Aren't you in the middle of recording an album or something? We are. We're recording. Yeah. We'll post recording in a studio. Yeah. On Instagram, I saw a photo of, I don't know if it's your basement
谢谢。你现在不是正在录制专辑还是什么的吗？是的，我们在录音。对。我们在录音室里进行后期录音。对。我在Instagram上看到一张照片，我不知道那是你的地下室……
or some room in the house. You have hundreds of instruments in this room. And where is that in your house? And did you have that growing up? And your kids love that? Or what's in it? Oh, no, no. I didn't, we didn't have any instruments.
还是家里的某个房间。那个房间里有几百种乐器。那是你家里的什么地方？你小时候有那种房间吗？你的孩子们喜欢那个吗？或者里面有什么？哦，不，不。我没有，我们没有任何乐器。
I had a blocky. Yeah. Were you facing a wall with a desk? Yeah, I had a desk in the basement. So that's like a Chicago thing? Yeah, yeah. Just put the kids in the basement against a wall. A lack of visuals, did me a lie.
我有一个积木。对。你当时是面对着墙上的书桌坐着的吗？对，我地下室里有一张书桌。所以那是芝加哥式的吗？对，对。就是把孩子们关在地下室里面对着墙。缺乏视觉刺激，骗不了人。
Oh, God. I have to say, I was asked to come out here last night. Yes. And I was like, oh, that's exciting. I went to sleep, and I dreamt that you were my best friend. Yeah. Yeah, good luck. And I've been to a lot of people have had that dream.
哦，天哪。我得说，我昨晚被邀请到这里来。是的。当时我想，哦，那太令人兴奋了。我睡着了，还梦见你成了我最好的朋友。对。对，祝你好运。而且我听说很多人都做过那个梦。
Yeah, I have that dream every night. So in my dream, I get so excited about getting to do this that I go and tell you, and you start crying. Because I ruined the surprise of me being here for you, because I forgot that you were on the show too, because I was excited about meeting you. No! Oh. Yeah. How many times has that happened?
对，我每晚都做那个梦。所以在我的梦里，我为能参加这个节目感到异常兴奋，于是我跑去告诉你，结果你竟然哭了。因为我毁了自己突然出现给你一个惊喜的计划，因为我忘了你也是节目的嘉宾，当时我光顾着兴奋能见到你了。不！哦。对。这种情况发生过多少次？
By the way, I didn't hear that, but now I know. I rehearsed my little bit with Andy Randy all day. And I got your name wrong. That's all right. No, now I read a recent interview of yours where I love this because I love talking about this. I'm a musician as well. I study piano for 20 years, but classical now.
顺便说一句，我刚才没听清，但现在我知道了。我一整天都在和安迪·兰迪排练我的小短剧。结果我把你的名字叫错了。没关系。不，我最近读了你的一篇采访，我太喜欢了，因为我喜欢聊这个。我也是个音乐人。我学了20年钢琴，不过现在学的是古典乐。
What you do is stunning, by the way. And so I love what you said about creating music. It's something about your mind disappears, but you're also present at the same time, and that's when you become creative. Like, explain that, because I think that's fast name, because I only got the disappearing part. LAUGHTER Well, that's helpful, isn't it? I mean, that's like, that's I think that's fast name because I only got the disappearing part. Well, that's helpful, isn't it?
顺便说一句，你弹得太惊艳了。所以我很喜欢你对创作音乐的评价。大意是你的思维消失了，但你同时又保持着清醒的当下，这就是你产生创意的时候。能解释一下吗，因为我觉得这太迷人了，我只记住了“消失”的那部分。笑声 好了，这很有帮助，不是吗？我是说，这就像，这就像……我觉得这太迷人了，我只记住了“消失”的那部分。好吧，这很有帮助，不是吗？
I mean, that's like, that's like, that's one of the, we all look for things to do that are, a way to kind of transport ourself outside of the burden of being in our bodies or be. Jason, James Cummings for that, yeah. Yeah, yeah. But so you kind of have one foot in and one foot out. Oh, I just think that you just try and put yourself
我是说，这就像，这就像，这是其中之一，我们都在寻找能做的事情，一种能让我们暂时超脱于身处肉体之累之外的方式，或者是……杰森·詹姆斯·卡明斯为此而生，对。对，对。所以你算是一只脚踩进去，一只脚踩出来。哦，我只是觉得你只是在努力让自己……
in the path of doing something creative. And what I feel like I get out of it more than anything is these moments that just kind of go away without me having to consciously try and kill time or be thinking about something that I don't have control over. I think a lot of games, crossword puzzles, those time sucks. A lot of things do that, but I think that there's something nice about having activities
走在做一件有创意的事情的路上。而我从中得到的，比什么都多的是那些转瞬即逝的时刻，不需要我去刻意地消磨时间，也不用去思考那些我无法掌控的事情。我觉得很多游戏、填字游戏，那些都是时间黑洞。很多事情都能做到这一点，但我认为拥有这样的活动是一件很美好的事：
that you come back from that experience with something that wasn't there before, like a writing or a song. I love that. I love that. Can I ask? I just want to calm down. OK.
当你从那种体验中走出来时，你带走了一些以前并不存在的东西，比如一段文字或一首歌。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我能问个问题吗？我只想冷静一下。好吧。
Yeah. So, but I would let the robot speak. I would ask this to any musician as I would like a writer of like books or screenplays. I'm assuming when you write a screenplay or a book, you're writing and then the next word kind of falls in next and how should the story go and it just kind of falls out in a natural progression. Is it the same way when you're strumming and you're kind of trying to come up with a new song and you find a good rhythm and then just naturally because you have great taste?
对。所以，不过我会让机器人来说话。我会向任何音乐家提出这个问题，就像问写书或剧本的作家一样。我猜当你写剧本或书的时候，你一边写，下一个词就自然而然地接上了，故事该怎么发展就顺其自然地推进。当你弹吉他或尝试创作新歌，找到一个好节奏，然后因为你品位极高，就自然而然地……
Oh, this chord would sound good after that. And by the end of a few minutes, you've got yourself a song. Is it that easy? Or say what to that? I, that, that, that, that, that, that can happen, but it doesn't, that's not normally how it happens. What, is it, is it normally like there's a certain structure,
哦，这个和弦在这个后面听起来会很棒。几分钟后，你就创作好了一首歌。有这么简单吗？还是说怎么回事？我，那，那，那，那，那，那可能会发生，但通常不是这样的。那，是，通常是像有一种特定的结构，
a certain chord has to follow, another sharp thing? Like, is it really, it will be? Oh, you do? Well, you listen to... You listen to... You listen to... You listen to... You listen to...
一个特定的和弦必须跟着另一个尖锐的东西？就像，真的是那样吗？哦，是吗？嗯，你听……你听……你听……你听……你听……
You listen to... I love it. I love you so much. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. How?
你听……我太喜欢了。我太喜欢你了。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。怎么回事？
How does music... How does music... How does music... It's like math equation. Yeah. I'm not... I'm not... I'm not... I'm not... I'm not... I'm not a question. I'm not a question. I range. No. Not to shoot.
音乐是怎么……音乐是怎么……音乐是怎么……这就像数学公式。对。我不是……我不是……我不是……我不是……我不是……我不是在问问题。我不是在问问题。我有范围。不。不是为了开枪。
Sorry. Not to shoot. I'm not no thing. I'm not assessing. See, I've got a battery packet. Oh, no. Oh, my God. Help me, Jim.
抱歉。不是为了开枪。我没在说那事。我没在评估。看，我身上戴着电池包。哦，不。哦，天哪。救救我，吉姆。
Help you. I can help you. You're like, you improvise conversation all the time, because you have a vocabulary. You learn a vocabulary, and you learn certain phrases and things that you like, and you express yourself, and you tend to repeat some of those things, because you know they're effective
救救你。我能救你。你就像，你一直在即兴对话，因为你词汇量丰富。你学习词汇，学习你喜欢的某些短语和表达方式，你表达自己，并且你往往会重复其中一些，因为你知道它们很有效……
in how you're able to communicate when you use those. There's no different with music. There are certain building blocks of the vocabulary that you get from your record collection and from things that you like and things you care about and other songs that you've written. And eventually, it does become sort of conversant in a way that you can construct a sentence
能帮助你进行交流。音乐也是如此。你从唱片收藏中、从你喜欢和关心的事情中、以及你写过的其他歌曲中，获得了某些词汇的基石。最终，它确实变成了一种对话式的能力，让你只需坐下来，说一句“我不知道接下来会发生什么”，就能凭空构建出一个句子或一个故事。
or a story out of whole cloth just by sitting down and saying, I wonder what would happen next. But the most fun part about doing it is the discovery for yourself, that you don't really know where it's going to go. And that's the, I don't know, that's my favorite part of it. Isn't that a rad answer? Is that an ASS? I don't question.
但这样做最有趣的部分是为你自己寻找发现的乐趣，你真的不知道它会走向何方。这就是，我不知道，这是我最喜欢的部分。这不是一个绝妙的回答吗？这是一个好问题吗？我没问。
No, it's a good question, too. And Andy. Yeah, you guys are making fun of him. He's the only one that cares. Believe me, it's a great, great day. For the fun of him. He's the only one that cares. I believe he's the only one that cares. I'm just waiting for the fun of it, just for the sport. But Andy, you get that, right? I mean, that's what improv comedy is about, too.
不，这也是个好问题。还有安迪。对，你们都在取笑他。他是唯一一个真正在乎的人。相信我，这真的是个极好的一天。为了取笑他。他是唯一一个真正在乎的人。我相信他是唯一一个真正在乎的人。我只是为了好玩，为了看笑话才等的。不过安迪，你懂的，对吧？我是说，这也是即兴喜剧的真谛。
That's a similar language in that way. Yes, definitely. And especially when you're doing improv, like you learn little tricks or little rules, that they're not like the things, you know, discoveries pop in. Like, when I was doing improv on a regular, you know, like whatever eight shows a week or something, there were times where we'd be on stage and there'd be things coming out of
从某种意义上说，这是一种相似的语言。是的，绝对是的。尤其是当你做即兴表演时，比如你学到一些小技巧或小规则，它们不是那种死板的东西，你知道，灵感会突然闪现。就像，当我定期做即兴表演时，你知道，比如一周八场演出什么的，有时我们在舞台上，有些话会脱口而出……
my mouth that I didn't know. Like it just felt like autopilot and like, holy shit, I'm good at this, you know. And so, but that doesn't happen now. But it is, you learn tricks to kind of just keep the ball in the air until you have that real moment of inspiration, like the really new thing. Yeah. Jeff, can I switch gears? Your son, Spencer, is still playing drums?
连我自己都不知道。就像进入了自动驾驶模式，心想，卧槽，我太擅长这个了，你知道的。所以，虽然现在不会那样了。但确实，你会学会一些小技巧，让谈话继续下去，直到你真正获得灵感的那一刻，那种真正全新的东西。对。杰夫，我能换个话题吗？你儿子斯宾塞还在打鼓吗？
He is, yeah. And so my other son, Sammy, is singing with me. And not in Wilco, but we make records. My solo records are mostly with my kids. It's incredible. We came, do you remember years ago? We came to see with Madison Square Garden. And I was with Fred, Armour Sid, and Amy,
是的，还在打。然后我的另一个儿子萨米在跟我一起唱歌。不是在威尔科乐队里，但我们一起录唱片。我的个人唱片大部分都是和我的孩子们一起录的。这太不可思议了。我们来过，你还记得多年前吗？我们去麦迪逊广场花园看演出。当时我和弗雷德、阿默·西德还有艾米在一起，
and we went in there, and then these guys go on, and Wilcoe go on, and then Jeff welcomes his son, and Spencer was like, 12 of the time, maybe. I think it was his 13th birthday. It was, it was his 13th birthday, that's right. That's what he just said. And he got up, yeah. That's what he just said.
我们进去了，然后这几个人上台了，威尔科上台了，接着杰夫迎出了他的儿子，斯宾塞当时大概12岁吧。我想那是他的13岁生日。对，那是他的13岁生日，没错。这就是他刚刚说的。他上台了，对。这就是他刚刚说的。
He just said it just now. Yeah, he said it. Holy shit. Yeah, I don't know He just said it just now. Holy shit. Yeah, I don't know how you do it. But here he goes on, he's 13, and he plays with you guys at Madison Square Garden. That's so cool.
他刚刚才说过。对，他说过了。卧槽。对，我不知道你是怎么做到的。但他上台了，13岁，和你们一起在麦迪逊广场花园演出。太酷了。
Was he cool with it or was he nervous? He was pretty nervous, but he was cooler than I would have been, for sure. Yeah, you don't know fear of losing. And cooler than I was, actually, on stage looking at him, like I'm forgetting the lyrics, you know, because I'm so worried about him You know, yeah, yeah, do you commonly get anxious in front of a large audience? No, I'm here all the time I know what and I mean, Andy as well, I'm sure you guys have had, like, we also have had
他当时觉得很酷还是觉得紧张？他挺紧张的，但他肯定比我当时要酷得多。对，你不知道失败的恐惧。而且实际上比我在台下看着他时还要酷，我当时都快忘词了，因为我太为他担心了。你知道，对，对，你在大观众面前通常会感到焦虑吗？不，我一直都在这儿，我知道……我是说，安迪也是，我相信你们也曾有过……
probably moments where you have a performance, whether it's live or on camera, that you're totally relaxed or, and you might think it's not that great, and it probably isn't, but I do my best over the night, I got a healthy level of anxiousness or nerves. Do you like to find that place?
可能也有过这样的时刻：你的某次表演，无论是现场还是面对镜头，你完全放松，或者你可能觉得没那么好，其实也确实一般，但我会尽力在当晚保持一个健康程度的焦虑或紧张感。你喜欢找到那种状态吗？
healthy level of anxiousness or nerves. Do you like to find that place? I mean, not really. You know. I mean, I- You'd rather just be totally- Yeah, I, for this, you know, bullshitting, being funny while bullshitting. Right.
健康程度的焦虑或紧张感。你喜欢找到那种状态吗？嗯，其实并不喜欢。你知道的。我是说，我——你宁愿完全——对，我，对于这个，你知道的，胡扯，在胡扯的同时搞笑。对。
It's much better to just be free and Lucy Goosey and not, you know, because I, it shuts me down. Being nervous shuts me down. It doesn't give you that little bit more energy that you might have for... No, and I just, I just don't work that way. What is nervous? What would make you nervous? Um...
最好还是完全自由、无拘无束的，不要，你知道的，因为我，紧张会让我整个人封闭起来。紧张会让我大脑宕机。它不会给你带来哪怕多一点点的能量去……不，我就是，我就是不习惯那样。什么叫紧张？什么会让你紧张？嗯……
A glass eye. Real answer. No. I hope not. No, like, well, like if I had to, like, sing. Yeah. You know, it's, do something like that. Alright, well, if I had to sing, yeah, it's do something like that. All right, let's hear it.
玻璃眼珠。真实的回答。不。我希望不会。不，比如，如果我必须得……唱歌。对。你知道的，做类似这样的事情。好吧，如果我非得唱歌的话，对，就是做那种事。好吧，让我们听听。
There we go. Just to the national anthem. Just to the national anthem. Oh, no, I'm not gonna. But I still get nervous when I do improv now. Yeah, because for years, too, even after I years too, even after like after I was a grownup And I was doing, you know, grownup improv I mostly would just do monologues stuff because a lot of the long-form improv will have a guest monologist especially the the UCB
这就对了。就唱国歌吧。就唱国歌。哦，不，我才不唱。但我现在做即兴表演时依然会紧张。是的，因为多年来，甚至在我多年以后，甚至在我长大成人之后，我还在做（你知道的）成年人的即兴表演，我大部分时间都只是做独白，因为许多长篇即兴表演都会有一个客串独白者，尤其是UCB
Ascat version has somebody come and tell monologues and then the people improvise based stuff of that So I would do that a lot and I'm very used to just sitting and being myself, you know, venue kind of thing. But to actually have to do improv is now scary, because it's a different, you know, it's like I don't do it all the time, and the time when you say people will ask me, like do you wanna come do our improv show,
阿斯卡特版本会请一个人来讲独白，然后大家根据这些内容进行即兴表演。所以我经常那样做，我非常习惯只是坐着做我自己，你知道，那种场馆式的演出。但现在真正要去做即兴表演其实很吓人，因为那是一种不同的……你知道的，就像我不是一直在做，每当有人问我——比如你想不想来我们的即兴表演秀？
and I'm always saying like, I don't wanna leave the house to get nervous. Yeah. Yeah. What about you, Jeff? What makes you nervous? I think it's good to not be too relaxed. I think it means you care when you're a little bit nervous.
我总是说，我才不想为了去感到紧张而离开家门呢。对。对。你呢，杰夫？什么会让你紧张？我觉得不要太放松是件好事。我认为那意味着你还在乎，当你感到有点紧张的时候。
Oh, yeah. You know? But I feel confident and nervous most of the time. Do you feel confident and or nervous to sing us a song right now? Wait, what? I want it. We can't pay for that. I didn't bring a guitar.
哦，对。你知道吗？但我大部分时间都既自信又紧张。此时此刻，你觉得自己有信心或紧张得能给我们唱首歌吗？等等，什么？我想听。我们可付不起这个演出费。我没带吉他。
And yeah, you didn't pay for that. You didn't do. Yeah. I haven't signed the release yet. Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh, Oh! Oh no! Oh my goodness.
而且，对，你没付钱。你没做。对。我还没签免责声明呢。哦！哦！哦！哦！哦！哦，不！哦，天哪。
Is that your son? That's Sammy. That's Sammy. Hey, man! Hey! This is so wild. This is so wild. Rep in the local head shop that just went under.
那是你儿子吗？那是萨米。那是萨米。嘿，兄弟！嘿！这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。代表那家刚刚倒闭的当地唱片店。
Oh no! Do they need someone to buy a large order of things? I'm brought my wallet. That's a large order of things. You know, I was going to say, I can sit closer to you, I think. Just be willing to say mine. I was going to say the thing that I've
哦，不！他们需要有人大量采购商品吗？我带钱包了。那是很大一笔采购。你知道，我本来想说，我觉得我可以坐得离你更近一点。只要愿意说出我的想法。我本来想说的是，这些年来我一直在舞台上学会习惯的一件事是……
learned to get used to on stage over the years is when it early on, and for a long time, I think you have an evolutionary ability to pick out danger that comes from being on the savanna or something, you know? Like, yeah. So I've had to teach myself how to ignore the guy yawning or like you're like, you can see it.
早期的时候，而且持续了很长时间，我想你有一种进化而来的能力，能挑出源自萨凡纳草原那种地方的危险信号，你知道吗？就像，对。所以我不得不教自己如何忽视那个打哈欠的人，或者像你这样……你能看出来。
Everybody can be having a great time. And I will find you. Right. I will find the person looking at their phone. That unlapping motherfucker I stare at him every time. Yeah, so I was like, I can see it through the mask too. I spent 20 years going, fuck is wrong with that guy. No, I know, I totally.
每个人都可能玩得很开心。但我偏能找到你。没错。我会找到那个在看手机的人。那个没合上腿的王八蛋，我每次都盯着他。对，所以我当时想，透过口罩我也能看出来。我花了20年时间在想，那家伙到底有什么毛病。不，我懂，我完全懂。
And finally, this person, delightful. I did a one-man show on Broadway called an Act of God and opening that... You guys didn't see it, fuck off. I did. I did. She saw it. Don't tell her what she did or didn't do.
最后，这个人，太可爱了。我在百老汇演过一个人的独幕剧叫《上帝的法案》，首演那天……你们没看过，滚一边去。我看过。我看过了。她看过了。别告诉她她看过还是没看过。
You and me, that's it. And it's a 90-minute monologue. It was impossible to memorize it, did it, and opening night. It was so great. It was laughing. I was impossible to memorize it. Did it, and opening night, it was so great. It was laughing. I just focused on one person. Not into it. Not into it.
就你和我，就这样。那是一场90分钟的独白。根本不可能把它背下来，结果呢，首演那天，效果棒极了。全场都在笑。根本不可能把它背下来，结果呢，首演那天，效果棒极了。全场都在笑。我只专注于一个人。完全不投入。完全不投入。
I didn't like it. I didn't like it. But you know what, though? I mean, it's very not to open up a larger discussion because you're going to play. But it is very natural. I think that we do that as humans. We can have 95% of our life going really, really well.
他不喜欢。他不喜欢。但你知道吗，不过，我是说，这其实非常……并不是要开启一个更大的讨论，因为你马上就要弹琴了。但这非常自然。我认为作为人类，我们都会那样。我们可以有95%的人生过得非常非常顺利。
And 5% doesn't work. There's always going to be 5%. And we focus on that. And it's taken me, I'm going to be 52, improbably. I agree. I don't believe you. I mean, good God. Look at that. Why? Why, Andy, go on.
而那5%不顺利。总会存在那5%。而我们偏偏专注于那5%。我花了……我马上要52岁了，难以置信。我同意。我不信。我是说，天哪。看看那个。为什么？为什么，安迪，继续说。
Wow. But it's taken me this long. It's only been within the last couple of years that I realized that, like, yeah, I'm so stupid for focusing on that shit. Why wouldn't I focus on all the stuff that's happening? Twitter is based on it. Yeah.
哇。但我花了这么久。直到最近几年我才意识到，像我那样去关注那些破事，真的是太蠢了。为什么我不去关注所有正在发生的好事呢？推特就是建立在这个基础上的。对。
I think Twitter is based on that, but I bet. That's true. That's the reality. All right. All right. So. I am an American Aquarium Trunker, I assassin down the album. I'm hiding out in the big city play, what was I thinking when I let go of you? Let's forget about the two tight-knit game
我觉得推特就是建立在这个基础上的，但我敢打赌。确实如此。就是这么个现实。好吧。好吧。所以。我是个美国水族馆的流浪汉，我在专辑里搞暗杀。我躲在大城市里弹奏，当我放手时我在想什么？让我们忘掉那场过于紧凑的游戏。
Let's sometimes just cross-eyed strangers This is not a joke so please stop smiling What was I thinking when I said it didn't hurt? I wish I knew how to play drums. I want to glad viewers brown eyes Green and take you from the inside Baby hold on tight You were so right when you said I've been drinking
让我们有时只做对眼相望的陌生人 这不是开玩笑所以请别笑了 当我当时说它不痛时我在想什么？ 我希望我知道怎么打鼓。我想让观众们高兴 棕色的眼睛，绿色的眼睛，从内心深处带走你 宝贝抓紧了 你说我一直在喝酒时真是太对了
What was I thinking when we said good night? Yeah! And that is so cool. Wow, so cool. Wow. Thank you guys. Amazing. I think what I think is so incredible is how many...
当我们说晚安时我在想什么？耶！这太酷了。哇，太酷了。哇。谢谢你们。太棒了。我觉得最不可思议的是，有多少……
This is what I think about all the time with you guys. You successful musicians like you. You have so many songs in your head that at any moment you just call upon them and you know, you know them, you must have hundreds of songs in your head. I do, actually, yeah, I do, it sits in, and I'll bet you, well, you're talking,
这就是我一直对你们这些成功音乐人想说的话。你们的脑子里有那么多歌，随时都能唱出来，而且你们对它们了如指掌，你们脑子里一定有几百首歌。我确实是，真的，我有，它们就在那儿，我跟你打赌，嗯，你在说，
is it, do you remember the lyrics as you get to that point in the song because the, because, I'm so sorry, it's doing it. This is me doing it right now, Will. as you get to that point in the song because the... Be-cut. I'm so sorry. That's okay. This is me doing it right now, Will. This is...
是不是，当你在歌里唱到那个地方时，你会记起歌词，因为，因为，我很抱歉，正在这样。这就是我现在的样子，威尔。当你唱到歌里那个地方时，因为……打断一下。我很抱歉。没关系。这就是我现在的样子，威尔。这是……
I just thought, well... No. Like, here's... Yeah, Jason. Imagine, Jason's brain is like an abacus inside. And it's just moving pieces. Well, like... But like for an actor, like when you're about to go out and do a play, you can't remember
我只是在想，嗯……不。就像，这里有……对，杰森。想象一下，杰森的大脑就像里面有一个算盘。它只是在移动部件。嗯，就像……但对演员来说，比如当你准备上台演一出戏时，你记不住
all your lines, right then. But when you get to the fridge, it's that line, hey, who stole my coat? You know, like it comes to you because of the blocking. The blocking. You're thinking, you say, Fridge, you actually are thinking about the model home and rest of development. Right. Or you, but I'm just saying, there are certain things that will jar the next line based on where you are in the news
你所有的台词，就在那个时候。但是当你走到冰箱前，就是那句台词，嘿，谁偷了我的外套？你知道，这就像是因为调度而自然想到的。调度。你在想，你说冰箱，你其实是在想样板房和《发展受阻》的其余部分。没错。或者你，但我的意思是，有些特定的事情会根据你在新闻中的位置来触发下一句台词
You can't remember all of the lines at once again another smart question. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah Yeah, there's a star I think Phil Oakser was I think he had to do some sort of testimony in court one time and he they were Drilling him about his anti-American lyrics or something like that and he couldn't remember them and they had to go get him a guitar Yeah, that's it. It might be total bullshit. I've heard that. I think I Went on I went on tour with Kenny Rogers. I was a Christmas elf and And I I love Kenny I grew up listening to his songs, but he would forget the lyrics sometimes on stage and he would just point the microphone to the audience.
你无法一次记住所有的台词，又是一个聪明的问题。对。对。对。对，有一个明星，我想菲尔·奥克斯（Phil Oakes）有一次好像不得不在法庭上做某种作证，他们盘问他关于反美歌词之类的事情，他记不起来了，他们不得不去给他拿把吉他。对，就是这样。这可能是完全胡扯。我听说过。我觉得我跟肯尼·罗杰斯一起巡演过。我当时是一个圣诞小精灵，而且我非常爱肯尼，我是听着他的歌长大的，但他有时在舞台上会忘词，他就把麦克风指向观众。
You got to know when the... So when? Right, exactly. Yeah, that's good. But anyway, yeah. And you played, did you play an Alph in this Christmas show? Yeah, that's hard to do when you've got a guitar or a ranger neck. Jeff, you don't know the gambler. Do you buy any chance to go to?
你得知道什么时候……那么什么时候？没错，完全正确。对，那很好。不过不管怎样，对。你弹了吗，你在这次圣诞演出里扮演了一个小精灵吗？对，当你拿着吉他或游侠领时，这很难做到。杰夫，你懂《赌徒》吗？你碰巧去吗？
Oh, no. OK. I don't think we're going to afford that, either. How are you right, hell? Anyway, Jeffrey, I can't tell you how excited we are and Jason and Will are, and they are that you're here. And Helen. I'm known Andy.
哦，不。好吧。我想我们大概也负担不起那个。你最近怎么样，地狱？不管怎样，杰夫，我无法告诉你我们有多兴奋，杰森和威尔也是，你来到这里。还有海伦。我认识安迪。
I've met Andy many more times than all of you guys. Wait, you guys know each other? Yeah, just from over the year. Yeah, from him being on the show a million times. Conan was our first ever performance in Uncle Tupelo from our first ever film. Oh, yeah, I mean, I'll go to Blom, man. And your stage director said, there's three million people
我见安迪的次数比你们所有人都多。等等，你们认识彼此？对，就从一年来。对，因为他上过这档节目一百万次。柯南是我们有史以来第一次演出的嘉宾，乌普勒科（Uncle Tupelo）来自我们的第一部电影。哦，对，我的意思是，我要去布隆，老兄。你们的舞台导演说，有三百万人在
watching, don't fuck it up. Yeah. That's a recipe for success. I want to tell you, last year, we would have killed for that number. I was wondering how accurate that was. Yeah, yeah. No, they just, the numbers keep going down.
观看，别搞砸了。对。那是走向成功的秘诀。我想告诉你，去年，我们会为那个数字拼命的。我当时在想那有多准确。对，对。不，他们只是，数字一直在下降。
But Jeff Tweedie, thank you for being here. Oh, yeah. I don't want to take a lot of your time. Andy Rickard, thank you for being here. Let, yeah. I don't want to take a lot of your time. And you're Rick Good, thank you for being here. And you're Rick Good. Thank you, and thank you, Jeff Tweety. This is amazing. Thank you.
但是杰夫·特维迪，谢谢你能来。哦，对。我不想占用你太多时间。安迪·里查德，谢谢你能来。让，对。我不想占用你太多时间。还有安迪·里查德，谢谢你能来。还有安迪·里查德。谢谢你，也谢谢你，杰夫·特维迪。这太棒了。谢谢你。
Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Yeah, yeah, great to see you. Come see us play. Come through the fly chips. Thank you. Thank you.
非常感谢。非常感谢。非常感谢。对，对，很高兴见到你。来看我们演出。通过飞行芯片来。谢谢。谢谢。
Woo! Sean. Sean, are you kidding? He played a song while we were on the national. I don't know. And my face was just staring at him like an idiot. That's close. You guys got two guests.
呜！肖恩。肖恩，你在开玩笑吗？他趁我们在国家乐队时弹了一首歌。我不知道。我的脸就像白痴一样盯着他看。差不多了。你们有两个嘉宾。
Yeah. Thank you. Anyway. I'm still a little rocked by the whole experience, beyond that. Yeah, Andy Richter. I mean, he's one of my favorite people, one of the kindness, nicest.
对。谢谢。不管怎样。对于整个经历，我仍然有点震撼，除此之外。对，安迪·里查德。我的意思是，他是我最喜欢的人之一，最善良、最好的人之一。
I love him. So, and Andy, we didn't even get Andy, the three of us used to play cards a lot back in the day with Andy. A lot, a lot. Yeah, a lot. Like it's a problem. Like his problem. And Andy was always the funniest guy at the table, always. And he would, I remember when somebody had a bunch of snacks
我爱他。所以，安迪，我们甚至没有让安迪，我们三个以前经常和安迪一起玩牌。经常，经常。对，经常。就像这是一个问题。就像他的问题。而且安迪总是桌上最搞笑的人，总是这样。而且他会，我记得当有人拿了一堆零食时
in my old place in Venice, and he came down the stairs and somebody had brought some fudge. And Andy comes down the stairs, and he's got fudge all over his mouth. And he comes down and he goes, I learned from the fudge, but somebody must have eaten it. And it was the funniest, the stupidest bit. I love stupid bits. He'd fit. He'd fit. He'd fit. He'd fit. He'd fit. He'd fit. The funny is the stupidest fit I love stupid bits.
在我威尼斯的老住处，他从楼下来，有人带了一些软糖。安迪下楼来，他的嘴上沾满了软糖。他下来然后说，我从软糖里学到了东西，但一定有人把它吃掉了。这是最搞笑的，最愚蠢的段子。我喜欢愚蠢的段子。他会合群。他会合群。他会合群。他会合群。他会合群。他会合群。搞笑是最愚蠢的段子，我喜欢愚蠢的段子。
Well, the only thing that I wish Jeff could have stayed to play, maybe if we had more time is a, is a, is a sweeter song, you know, maybe like a, a lulla, bye! Oh, the love, bye. Bye! Bye! Bye! Love you, thank you!
好吧，我唯一希望杰夫能留下来弹奏的，如果我们有更多时间的话，是一首，是一首，是一首更甜美的歌，你知道，也许像一首，摇篮曲！哦，爱，拜拜。再见！再见！再见！爱你，谢谢！
Bye! Love you, thank you! Bye! Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile.
再见！爱你，谢谢！再见！微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。
Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile.
微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。
Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smile. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armstrong, and Bennett Barberco. Smartless Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered, as the King of Pop, or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator.
微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。《Smartless》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿姆斯特朗（Rob Armstrong）和贝内特·巴尔韦科（Bennett Barberco）100%有机且手工匠心制作。《Smartless》自2009年去世以来，世界一直在纠结迈克尔·杰克逊应该被如何铭记，是作为流行音乐之王，还是作为怪物。我是利昂·奈法克（Leon Neyfakh），《Fiasco》的主持人和《Slow Burn》的共同创作者。我是杰·斯穆斯（Jay Smooth），一位嘻哈记者和文化评论员。
Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancelable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store.
迈克尔·杰克逊在1993年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》（Think Twice, Michael Jackson）讲述了在此之前和之后发生的故事。在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊看起来似乎无法被取消。我们深入探讨了当我们听到杂货店里播放《比利·让》（Billie Jean）时，我们许多人内心的复杂感受。
Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art. Listen to Think Twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music App. music app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过对亲眼目睹故事发展的数十次独家采访，《三思》试图调和我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这个人的矛盾情感，以及我们对他艺术的深沉热爱。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以收听《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》，或者你可以在 Amazon Music App 上免广告、无间断地狂听整个系列。音乐应用。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。